i actually did not know what 990s were
before all of this happened the
accountant handled that like i i don't
know what that is it is such a trip now
to hear the word that the the term 990s
i'm like uh it's like triggering this
doesn't seem safe for us
this 990 structure this non-profit
system structure this is like deeply
unsafe like this is being literally
weaponized
against us how was it how was it just a
form
unsafe
and then because it reveals where the
money's going yeah yeah but i mean this
is the you know this is partially our
fault for continuing to overuse the word
weaponized because now he's like just a
form can be weaponized blm used to stand
for black lives matter now it stands for
buy lovely mansions
oh that's really good thank you
here's the problem with that every year
all of us filed tax returns every year
all of us know that we've got to report
income and there are certain there are
certain forms that we have to fill and
then these people she is triggered by
the irs charity rules